hi i'm alvin and today i'm going to show
you how to make some of my most viral
recipes
[Music]
one thing that i was really lucky enough
to be able to do was to work a lot with
our tasty international teams and one
particular trip i remember was actually
with rye and we went to japan to work
with the tasty japan team so one of our
biggest goals in japan was just find
this amazing viral food that they sort
of do and try to see if we can recreate
it one of the dishes that definitely
caught our eye was these jiggling
pancakes that were a lot thicker than
you normally were but apparently we're a
lot fluffier and a lot lighter than your
traditional american pancake and we sort
of went to the source and went to this
cafe that just served them and were
known for them there's a lot of
transparency into the cooking process in
japan with a lot of class windows it was
such a pleasure to be able to just see
how things were done
ray and i sort of put our heads together
to figure out how to recreate this i'm
pretty happy with how this one turned
out it maybe wasn't a hundred percent as
jiggly or as fluffy as the ones we eat
in japan but i would say it's pretty
close
it was just such an amazing experience
to travel to a country and to explore
food culture with someone that knows it
so well such as create appreciate it
respect it but also put our own spin on
it i think that's something that i
really really love doing
when i was in college i really didn't
know how to bake at all i really wanted
to save money so i would actually take
ingredients from my dining hall from you
know the ice cream bar where they had
like chocolate chips or a nutella or
peanut butter and kind of bring them
back to my dorm and throw them together
with a little flower and try and come up
with the baked good that was edible that
i could feed my floor mates that could
get friends finally and one thing that i
really found was that people just
absolutely love cookies whether it's
eating them whether it's making them
cookies became the thing that i just
really wanted to nail and this is a
recipe that i'm really really proud of
coming up with this recipe i knew it had
to be better than store-bought cookie
dough or things that people are used to
taking home and baking or getting at the
store and i really looked into using
different kinds of chocolate i used to
work at a bakery in new york where i was
just absolutely in love with their
chocolate chip cookies in i knew it
needed to be chewy on the inside i knew
it needed to be a little crispy on the
outside and it had to be this thing that
you would crave over and over and over
again one secret that i did learn was
that the dough should be rested for at
least 24 to 36 hours because what that
does is that helps the flour absorb all
the egg and the sugar and the butter and
really allow certain processes to start
developing flavors inside the fridge
that you would lose if you bake the
cookie dough right away because i think
it gives it a more caramel toffee like
flavor which i absolutely love
mozzarella stick onion ring was one of
my more proud creations one thing that i
really love to do when i'm coming up
with ideas is just think of two really
really delicious things that people love
and somehow combine it into something
that's even more delicious i really
wanted to combine mozzarella sticks with
something else kind of lay awake at 2
a.m thank you like what can i make with
mozzarella sticks as i was about to fall
asleep i think my brain just drifted off
and thinking about shrek and i was like
oh onions like onion rings like oh my
god that's so cool and i was like wait
is this even possible you know to quote
the famous green ogre ogres are like
onions you know onions have layers and i
just started to picture cross-section of
an onion with all its concentric rings i
like kind of mentally isolated two of
them turns out if you use sliced cheese
it's almost the perfect whip it still
looks like an onion ring after it's been
fried and it did taste like a mozzarella
stick and it did taste like an onion
ring it was a very fun day
five layer brownie cheesecake was
probably one of my greatest
architectural feats if i would say so
myself i was actually studying
engineering in college not really a good
student to be honest but one thing that
i definitely did pick up was the ability
of how to approach a problem and how to
look at it from certain angles
especially when things don't exist a lot
of times we're asked to do hypothetical
questions like if you wanted to
accomplish this how would you go about
achieving it and i learned that the
easiest way is to break down the problem
into its parts and kind of almost work
backwards cookie dough oreos and
brownies are very common in combination
and i wanted to take that further i
really wanted to turn the flavor profile
of like a triple stacked brownie into
something else i wanted to turn it into
more of like this spectacle dessert that
you could really wow everybody at a
party with and i just absolutely love
layers and clean layers so that was
something that i set out to do was to
turn a triple decker brownie into a
cheesecake the challenge with this
recipe is that all of these elements all
bake at different times different
temperatures and have different
thicknesses i kind of wanted to go after
the vibe of when you go to cheesecake
factory and they set down this slice of
this beautifully cut and assembled
cheesecake i really didn't know how this
was going to go until i made it and i
had to do a lot of replanting and
thinking and being able to try to
predict how the food would behave in a
way that i had never done before i was
hoping that the brownie batter would not
get dry i guess that the cream cheese
and the mixture would give the brownie
moisture it's really gratifying to pull
something like this off especially when
you have never really done this before i
guess i feel really happy relieved that
it actually worked after the brownie and
cheesecake were set that's when i put
the oreos and the cookie dough on top
i don't try to do recipes a lot of times
because i think i really enjoy the
challenge of getting it right on the
first of the second try kind of
nerve-wracking to cut it open because
you really don't know how it's going to
turn out until you actually slice it
open and see the layers and to my luck
it really worked out well i was able to
see
all four elements in their entirety i
love to spend time just thinking about
the food and really just trying to guess
and predict how food is going to behave
and sometimes i really just sit down and
write things down and try to map out or
draw out how certain foods to look
before and after and so for this one i
thought about it a lot and made some
decisions and that's the sort of
approach that i like to take because
there's something really cool about
trying something that's completely new
and then somehow landing it on the first
try
when i try to come up with an idea for a
recipe what i really want to do is be
able to make people go like wow and
really show them something that they are
familiar with but maybe in a new way or
maybe something that is new to them but
in a familiar way it's always about
taking an element of something that
people know twisting in and making it
cooler making it different combining
with other things the end result is to
make people go wow that's sort of
usually the approach i take when i want
to really showcase food to people in a
cool way so for the eight desserts in
one cheap pan it kind of came from a
time where it was the holidays i'd seen
a lot of videos kind of pop up around
like you know desserts and baking and
pie and food network actually released
this one video that was pretty cool it
was like four pies baked in the same
sheet pan and to myself i was like wow
like that's really smart but can i take
it even a little further i know that pie
is just one dessert there are a lot of
desserts out there and a lot of baked
goods that people like to eat my hunch
was that around you know christmas time
or on the holidays usually at these
potlucks or parties there would be a
wide spread of desserts you know range
from cookies to brownies to cheesecakes
to pies i think this crazy idea came
about because in my head i was like man
what happens if you just kind of put all
those desserts together like is there a
way to take every single dessert that
everybody loves and turn it into just
one thing i think that's kind of how the
idea was born is i basically thought of
what can i use to serve this giant
dessert and how do i make sure that
everybody gets a piece they want because
sometimes when you bring a dessert to a
party not everybody likes brownies not
everybody likes cheesecakes but is there
a way to make sure that no matter who
you are at the party you're gonna have
one piece that's gonna speak to you and
that's how i sort of designed this eight
desserts in one sheet pan i wanted to
sort of build it in a way where if you
cut it in the precise manner you would
end up with just like a bunch of
different flavors you wouldn't really
cut it just along where the flavors met
but you'd be able to get pieces or bars
that would have two flavors three
flavors and the golden crown is when you
get that piece with all four flavors in
them the challenge with designing this
was that no matter what piece you get
the flavor should still go together so
you kind of have to play this weird like
math mix and match game of like do these
two flavors go together okay if this
goes together with this then this must
be next to here it was a lot of mean or
drawing things on a piece of paper and
crumpling it up like you do in the
movies and throwing it in the trash can
after a lot of trial and error i managed
to get a certain layout of which
desserts should go in which area in the
pan so that no matter which piece you
got it would always taste great
[Music]
i was going to attempt something as
crazy as this a couple years ago i would
have never imagined that i feel like
once i started to do more and more
videos for buzzfeed did i realize that
food was pretty much everything to me
not only am i someone who loves to eat
but it does make me happy and it does
make me proud of when i'm able to pull
off a certain dish or a certain thing
that i've seen on the internet because
i'm not classically trained everything
is really just approaching something and
trying to apply certain rules and
properties about food to see if i can
actually make this crazy thing happen
this mirror cake i literally just saw it
when i was scrolling through instagram
and i was like man this cake is so cool
how do they do that it's like some crazy
beautiful technique and i want to figure
it out and after doing hours and hours
of research and a couple of tests i was
able to pull off something that looked
very close to what these professional
pastry chefs and these cake decorators
are making on instagram no matter what i
do i know i will always love to showcase
food in a beautiful way in a way that
people haven't seen before no matter
whether it's recipe videos or whether
it's a story i just want to be able to
make people feel a wide range of
emotions excitement happiness joy
craving and i don't think that'll ever
change we're pretty fortunate that we've
been able to make an audience of you
know millions of people there's nothing
like being able to feed someone i think
that's really what i believe and that's
why i love to cook it's not only that
i'm able to make fun food videos that
can touch a lot of people on the
internet but also be able to actually
create food with my hands share them
with people that i care about or people
that i want to hang out with it really
fosters a great sense of companionship
friendship and just a stronger
connection between people and great that
we have to eat every day because
otherwise i might get bored it's funny
because when i started out i was really
just borrowing a camera from my floor
mate that i had made friends with
because i gave him a cookie one time and
just recording whatever i was baking
that day or whatever i took from the
dining hall and posting them on who
knows where one day i was connected with
a frozen yogurt chain because they
wanted a little amateur videographer to
come in and do these like short little
froyo videos one day a buzzfeed manager
saw these videos and reached out to me
and was like hey would you ever want to
come and make a couple of food videos
for us and at that time tasty did not
exist the food internet situation was
really nothing when tasty was born i was
along to see it grow and to really see
how much it touched people's lives and i
was really proud of that we all love
food and we all support each other and
we all love to showcase food with video
in a way that is very unique to our
styles it's really cool to see people
tag each other and being like oh my god
this reminded me of you oh by the way
how's it going i haven't talked to you
in like five years and it's like that's
kind of crazy is that you know this
random cake got someone to mention
someone else because they knew that
someone would love this piece of content
i think that was really what resonated
with me and why i strive to push to make
even better food videos day after day i
never ever think to myself like oh man
like i gotta go to work today it's
always been like oh like i want to make
this cool thing i want to get there as
soon as possible food just really brings
people together no matter who you are i
can honestly say that
99 of my friends are my friends because
i've given them food i love making these
videos not for myself but for other
people because i really love how food is
cool and i want to show them that
[Music]
you